alors quoi de beau bonjour à toutes et à
tous alors quoi de beau ce week-end ce
dimanche c'est la fête des numismates
donc pour leur rendre hommage on va
faire un petit pile ou face si je fais
pile je présente pas la météo si je fais
face je la présente
pile
c'est pile
j'ai pas dit qu'est-ce qui était pile
qu'est-ce qui était face mais ça c'est
pile donc la météo voilà on est parti on
va refaire un pile ou face pour le
deuxième jour de la météo c'est reparti
ok on commence parce que c'était pas
pile
il faut que je fasse pile pour pas
présenter
ah pile je présente pas la météo des
deux jours vous avez le temps de la voir
normalement on va donc partir à votre
rencontre pour savoir si vous savez ce
que c'est un numismate pile ou face j'y
vais
pile
j'y vais pas
alors est-ce que vous savez ce que c'est
un numismat monsieur absolument pas en
quoi un quoi un numismate
des pièces de monnaie non ouais c'est un
collectionneur de pièces monsieur ah oui
effectivement on va faire un pile ou
face parce qu'en fait dimanche c'est la
journée des numismate
donc ça c'est ça c'est face ça c'est
pile ou face
[Rires]
c'est très bon merci beaucoup allez le
gag et pile vous dites
face OK
bah bien joué
pile attention
[Rires]
de la joie
vous êtes contents pile ou face
[Rires]
[Musique]
est-ce que ça vous dit de jouer un pile
ou face non
je n'aime pas jouer
[Musique]
je défasse
il y aura pas de face
on fait un pile ou face madame
ok je comprends bonne journée
dommage
merde
j'ai gagné quoi j'ai gagné quoi vous
allez gagner le droit de rejouer c'est
tout
énorme ah c'est bien c'est pas mal c'est
bien
bam c'est repris encore
du coup tu me dis quoi Monsieur et vous
avez gagné quoi alors le droit de
rejouer
alors qu'est-ce que j'ai perdu surtout
ben le droit de rejoindre
[Rires]
pas des questions essentielles
ça dépend de la Croix
nécrophile moi j'ai rien compris
alors quoi de beau
[Musique]